- I heard that too.
I love Ed Sheeran.
I got to work with him on The Voice,
and you did a song with him, right?
- I did.
I've known Ed for years,
and I went to England to write with him,
and when I first sat down,
we were writing a song,
and he asked me who my first love was,
and I said, "It was my
fifth-grade girlfriend, Sarah,"
and he asked me these million questions,
and then at the end of the session,
he's like, "Hey, I got one more song.
Let's write this song about Sarah,"
and I said, "Do you wanna write a song
about my fifth-grade girlfriend?
I haven't talked to her in 45
years, and you wanna talk?"
And we wrote a song called Sarah
about my fifth-grade girlfriend.
- Do you wanna know why I
think that's such a great idea?
I feel like adults always say
like, "Oh, they're children.
What do they know of love,
or what do they know this?"
And I'm like, I think children,
they're not jaded yet.
- Oh, exactly.
- [Presenter] You know what I'm saying?
I think that kids feel everything.
I never tell my kids when they come home,
and they're seven and nine,
but they already are like,
"Oh, I love him."
Like, and I'm like,
"I truly believe you probably
do in your whole heart."
Like, I'm like, you know,
"You probably gonna change your mind,
but I'm just gonna let you know."
But like, but yeah, I just
think it's such a pure thing,
and there's no other experience
jading that, you know?
- Yes, I agree.
- Yeah.
- I agree.
- Yeah, that was there.
- I love the song.
Ed's such a great songwriter.